You say that we should not take glutathione supplements if we have cancer, but is it okay to take
NAC to help boost our glutathione levels naturally, or is it defeating the purpose?
If a person is in full remission of their cancer, I don't think they have any trouble taking
NAC. So, NAC is what NAC is. And NAC is the precursors to glutathione. So normally, in the mitochondria,
glutathione is recycled. That's how it works. That's how important glutathione is as the main
this main antioxidant of a cell. So, in the cell, you have mitochondria and they're making glutathione
and recycling glutathione, and they need cysteine and glycine as components to help with that
recycling process and magnesium and some other cofactors. So, NAC is typically given to help boost
glutathione levels. Now, if a person has is in kind of full-blown cancer, then I'd say no, you
shouldn't be adding too much anesthetal cysteine to the system unless it's testifying for that person,
but it typically would not. And you certainly wouldn't take like a glutathione, or the
like was able glutathione supplement if you have cancer. But if you're in remission,
helping with glutathione precursors, which NAC is, could help, you're not dealing with active
cancer that I'd say it's okay to take. But if you're dealing with active cancer, I'd say maybe
hold off on that.